el fiscal marcelo pecci fue asesinado en
la isla colombiana de barú cercana a la
turística ciudad de cartagena de indias
estaba encargado de investigar casos de
narcotráfico lavado de dinero y crimen
organizado en su país seguirá en la
lucha contra el crimen organizado en la
cima esto es muy doloroso muy duro he
conversado con el presidente iván duque
por teléfono que se comprometió conmigo
para darnos todo nuestro apoyo para
resolver el caso para buscar a los
responsables
también he conversado con el gobierno
americano con respecto a eso quienes
también a través de colombia van a
apoyar casos como el del futbolista
brasileño ronaldinho quien en 2020
intentó entrar en paraguay con un
pasaporte falso el del asesinato de la
hija de un gobernador regional le dieron
reconocimiento a nivel nacional e
internacional al fiscal de 45 años que
además investigaba el asesinato de dos
personas durante un festival paraguayo
mientras tocaba un grupo musical
colombiano conocido como el binomio de
euro
ya tenemos informaciones que están
siendo recolectadas en los actos
urgentes y que son de carácter reservado
que nos ayudarán a identificar a los
responsables de este lamentable hecho
una delegación de la policía paraguaya
formará parte del equipo de
investigación en colombia en el que
también participarán funcionarios de
eeuu